okay the people who are joining us we
are looking at graph databases
capabilities in upcoming version of
Wolfram language and reviewing some of
those capabilities and we have a bit of
background noise here that okay all
right so we've looked at a lot of this
before um
boy it's a shame that we've got names
like select and aggregate that
both similar to but different from the
relational database analogs of these
actually for instance the aggregate is
pretty similar so the design decisions
are in line the links the links won't
work because okay so do we have examples
and things here
yes some some basic examples
okay so these are raw Sparkle
capabilities here yes so that's why all
of those functions are prefixed with
sparkle to replicate exactly what a
standard says
okay all right so hey by the way for
goodness sake the more about should
point to the other database stuff and so
on right yes
um and this is okay so this
I mean shouldn't this be called graph
store package overview
right because that's what this is it's a
package
it's the graph store pack
correct
yes yes shall I edit it or do you want
to but you can edit all of the changes
and I'll integrate them okay for
instance we have the library link
it also doesn't mention package in the
first word link okay
um well okay fine look that come the
graphs store package
provides capabilities provides
capabilities for representing
queer Ian
and updating RDF graphs and datasets
um well as well as querying them using
the power of sparkle basically
yes
[Music]
you
well so basically the point here is that
um the package defines a symbolic layer
you
that can be used to make Sparkle queries
against local or remote
um
endpoints data sources what do you want
to say in the case of remote it's called
Sparkle and point in the case of the
general tourism or their store gets
local stores or remote
all remote Sparkle endpoints right yes
okay do you think endpoint is one word
one word
you
you
database links somebody's pointing out
the database link also doesn't say
package well it says okay so we're
saying it in the middle here um okay uh
Karl our live stream is asking about
integration of the stuff with the entity
framework
you know I have some
but they are not ready
okay and what do we think is ultimately
going to be the the way that that's
going to happen I mean is it going to be
that just like an entity store right now
so if we go to entity store um what
we're seeing is why is this so slow that
you know yeah and there could you please
report this again the both opening the
route guide page and going to an
individual page is super slow and that
you know we're seeing that you know
spinning discs and things getting there
so one one idea is to have an internet
to build an entity store backed by an
RDF store or spot lien point that means
where you have relational database you
could have an RDF store yes
seems highly sensible to me and then but
then the question is okay so then given
that entity store then the question is
what querying capabilities there are and
that entity store we have now provided
these relational query in capabilities
but are you saying that ultimately I
mean the thing I'm not understanding is
the relationship between I mean you know
one of the problems I was I was
realizing I was talking to somebody a
couple of days ago about the theory of
relational algebra and relational
calculus and all this kind of thing and
all these crazy you know normal forms
and I have to say it sounds like it's
just a wonderfully exotic signing area
by the time they have things like fifth
normal form and so on you know but those
are a lot of those are about sort of how
much replication of data there is when
you have different tables and foreign
keys and all this kind of thing and I
don't know what I mean triple stores
solver in a different way anyway what
I'm yakking about is you know when we
look at what can you do with an entity
store the most trivial thing is entity
property value stuff but then
what you're doing here is a quite
different way okay if we look at the
relational the things that we're
supporting for relational queries can
you also support those against the
sparkle endpoint or not yes so the idea
is that once we support an RDF store
it's an entity store argument then
entity filtered entity class sorted any
class aggregation they will be
translated to the corresponding spot or
queries automatically ok that means it's
just another back-end for entity store
but is are those relational type queries
really the ones that you know presume
look we've right now we've got three
types of queries we've got the the data
set like queries that can involve full
Wolfram language syntax we've got the
relational database queries which are a
more impoverished set that may depend on
what the actual relational database
back-end is and then we've also got the
sparkle query you know the things that
are supported in sparkle queries right
yes what about [ __ ] for example is that
yet another I mean we complete we should
presumably be able to back an NC store
with a [ __ ] DB instance is that right
or is that not the way where we should
be going with that
don't know about it I could you can tell
okay all right fine okay all of those
functions these new Sparkle functions
are basically the corresponding to the
intermediate layer in the relational
database project which is not yet
exposed so this is a solid foundation on
which we can build and I'm working on
some small super functions that will
make working with those RDF data easier
okay but I mean are we expecting that
for example we'll have a copy of our you
know pieces of our knowledge base in
Sparco form for different kinds of
querying than we are doing right now or
what implicitly yes because the ideas
that we can apply for instance a sparker
select to an entity type which means
that the entity type this implicitly
Bute as an RDF graph that means there's
a implicit conversion between entities
and RDF data for instance each entity
gets an IR I and so on okay but okay
swimming so the first step then is to
take all of our entities and give them
IR eyes that true yes I have a proposal
for that the future okay okay
and okay so that's interesting enough um
all right this is a very strange
statement used to identify physical or
abstract things it's basically just a
lot things to use to identify anything
well used to identify entities right
used as a unique identifier of of things
you need not necessarily because people
can mint different identifies for the
same thing also don't don't you use a
higher rise for four properties or am i
confused by that tone yeah
corporate yeah you do um
well it's like what would you say after
the word and a URL what is the URL it's
a
you cannot say
abstract things it just doesn't um but
I'm not gonna rewrite everything here
because I just don't think that I mean
there's a package and it's not it's an
experimental package and it's not
something where we're going to have
quite the same level of scrutiny
um okay hold on used to used as a basic
general identifier yes um
you
okay okay RDF triple okay I understand
oops
now the tests that you've got here
or the examples you're giving here ah
that seems a bit lighter examples but
yes so so they are distributed over
different places for instance the RTF
store has some more examples sparta
select tests a lot of examples okay but
you probably want to copy examples you
know um boy
well it's interesting it's interesting
to see this kind of I mean this is this
is sort of the promise of the Semantic
Web is that you can do stuff like this I
just can't imagine this is gonna work um
I mean it requires so many
correspondences of what you're actually
talking about that I cannot believe
people are going to get right well
that's what some future simple functions
too will do Constance I'm planning I are
I value which is similar to entity value
but for I eyes they can ask for the
properties retrieve the value for
certain property of an entity or entity
I I sinks again I just don't see where I
mean you know the examples you're giving
here yeah we know about these things
but I mean
I'm just confused about like like for
example you know Tim berners-lee's solid
thing do you understand what that is
that is that supposed to be generating
lots of other IR eyes that are being
thrown out on the web or something
know anything about it I'm not sure that
the thing is very alive anymore
select okay okay well look ya know I
realized that but I mean the fact is the
world isn't a big RDF store at this
point and there's no great well ok
nevermind um
okay let's take a look at this so there
says Sparkle varible
oh my gosh
I mean like I have no idea what Sparkle
evaluation it's doing some particular
things that happen to be doable by a
sparkle by sparkle server is that
correct yes
no you can't do this look look look look
represents a function
with where we were where we were what
are the possible names here
so so there's a long list of names and
we could maybe list them we got it list
them okay so this has got to say because
what you're doing here is completely
obscure right so this has got to say
Sparkle evaluation of quotes well what
are these things called and Sparkle
operations or what
I'm checking
they're called just functions okay well
okay what represents the bill ten
represents the built-in Sparkle Sparkle
function
with name with name let's just say with
a specified name
um
to be evaluated during
Sparkle growth pattern matron all right
yes the following possible named
possible bill
barkal functions include and then
there's going to be some big list of
them yeah maybe 50 or so things like
this TR Lin supster things that have a
more appropriate name for longer names
in our language yeah okay well and then
say what they are
yes yeah call on the livestream is
saying we should look at wiki data yes
I'm quite aware of wiki data um and we
have I mean arguably we should provide
specific functions just like we provide
Wikipedia data we should provide
specific functions for doing lookups and
wiki data
is there any reason not to do that
we could do that already once we have
IRI value that might help a lot for
beginners to work with that data yeah
okay all right let's keep looking here
um I mean there's so much here it's kind
of hard to
let's look at the guides here
you
RDF concepts sparkle query Sparkle
update
so those contain all the symbols to the
new
I understand so let's look at basic RDF
structures for a second here
you
we need to move that over
and please copy that over another places
where it needs to be used that's what
just happened here that's crazy
you
what is going on why am I not able to
write that
something is going on I'm press
come on V and nothing is happening see
it's flashing the Edit thing and nothing
is happening
uh that's just totally weird well I
guess I get to do the old-fashioned like
on our typewriter type thing just retype
it okay this is very odd this isn't
showing up yes it is okay all right
okay
um
that should be formatted differently
obviously yeah decoy is working on the
formatter
okay so these formats are now going to
the format pages that are for reading in
out those those formats correct did you
knit those formats so those formats are
not
boy this is like our XML capabilities
right so this this is going to be
generating elements which are part of
this package correct okay so if I read
in an RDF XML format right yes the the
thing that I get out is going to contain
things like I our eyes and RDF triples
and so on right correct
but those are pieces of the graph store
context correct yes so we had a
discussion with the import people or
threader we would need needs before
those before just work but they argued
that they would always work definitely
and they would just generate things
which are in the sparkle and in the
graph store context yes okay
did those things get knitted onto the
page for the import-export page no okay
needs to be done we can just do it right
now let me load up the right things and
want to do it okay is that the complete
set of formats that you have there are
more under spoke variants bug update so
in total dead read okay all right so all
of those need to be knitted onto the
format's page and each of these actually
has a formats page right yes
you
okay import-export boy there's a lot of
stuff here people better find this
useful um okay so let's go to the page
um let me go open the right thing here
you
Paige
no it's not for our page I'm sorry it's
a guide page wrong so it's we can go to
the main page actually here and
[Music]
okay importing and exporting okay so now
we've got formats here um
you
okay so we have to put these on so do
you have a guide page for graphs tour
formats no they all endorse might be
caught up on you okay so we've got
database formats here I wonder whether
we should put this here um so all of
those formats go in suite categories one
the biggest are RDF data hold on hold on
on this page where do they go do they go
in the section on like here with like
XML formats and things or do they go or
do you think they go along with database
formats I would say database formats so
but those formats a little bit higher
level than pure database formats
I understand but then we've also got
this scientific and medical data and all
that these are kind of content formats
here but this is a matter format more
like JSON and things do you agree yes so
so maybe we can say here RDF
and graph store should we say graph
story rdf and sparkle related it could
just be are there formats because that's
the majority then the only other formats
are the results of sparkle queries and
then the sparkle query and update
strings themselves
I think this is fine to say RDF and
SPARQL righted formats um I'm just
wondering where this should go
kind of seems odd that it's so far away
from XML yeah
but it is really like a data storage
thing maybe for import it might more go
under one because the user might not
care what it is in if it gets already of
data out but for certain applications
for export your user might wish to
specifically export to RDF XML okay so
wait a second so that's its own separate
thing down here so under XML formats we
should be listing RDF XML somewhere on
this page right yes and under Chasen
because list json-ld for instance okay
all right fine let's get to that in a
moment okay
hmm we haven't broken this out into a
separate Jason page arguably we should
do that because in any case these Jason
formats are getting kind of confusing
um
I think we should do that
okay so hold on this is that this is a
separate
okay so JSON related formats
that's a guide page do you know the
difference between these JSON formats
sons now I use raw Jason
okay this is going to require
um perhaps of JSON as well as a variety
of mappings between JSON data structures
and Wolfram language structures okay and
so this probably wants to gosh this is
going to um
I some somebody is going to have to try
and write see if you can write or get
written and rare if you can do this also
just we need basic descriptions here so
these things you know they do different
things
yeah
mustard lists this is roughly we see
each one is a slightly different twist
on what it's doing
yes while Jason and rod chasin basically
read the same Jason but represented
differently the others are built on top
like geo Jason expression Jason what's
Geo Jason um Jason format for including
chill craft and where is that where do
we have that I don't see it here in
dollar import formats it appears here
we might want to list it under this
since I've certainly heard of it I saw
it on the page it wasn't out here on
this part but it was on that actual page
no no I know yeah okay
sorry um okay so
domain-specific so that's where we have
and I mean there may be some other ones
here domain-specific JSON format so that
is where we have cheer Jason what was
the other one you were mentioning as
domain-specific maybe expression Jason
because it is as far as understand
particular for the Wolfram language no I
don't think that's the right way to
think about it here map nested
you
you
Oh
okay um full
I figured she would be better to say
nested mapped to Jason okay so now what
are the other ones here we've also got
you
you
okay what the heck is the difference in
JSON JSON means that as instead of
Association you have list of rules okay
you
maybe Dorian could review all of that
later because he seems to be the expert
on that right now okay and then these
other ones are UB JSON
that's a binary
you
okay
you
you
you
um well let's see I don't even know
geodata up 2j some but I don't know
exactly what that is and somebody will
have to fill that in um
by the way we arguably should set paren
and then the the name um the format name
in the low dot u BJ
it should play beyond this page there's
something for Dorian to look at hum and
Bryan of her beasts on
mustard lists and associations mapped to
UB JSON
and then we have beasts on
is there any other JSON I mean is there
any other format okay hold on
you
what is this thing is this
domain-specific or something
boy this seems to be domain-specific and
this is um okay so this is actually um
this is JSON
data storage formats um binary format
used by MongoDB etc and now you have one
here what was your one this is was your
as it was yours a data format thing what
was the one that you have for your RDF
stuff jason LD what does that stand for
link data okay
um JSON format for linked RDF data right
yes okay
sometimes linked and RDF are used as
synonyms but found in and yes another
one
Sparkle results Chason which encodes
results of a sparkle carry okay okay
hold on let me just get that um
you
musical Sparkle Sparkle results chasing
results singular results yes um that is
what a sparkle endpoint can send back
Palmer used by Sparkle and points all
right
we will this will need to be reviewed
bits at least to start okay
RDF and sparkle related formats ok
what's the what's the top one there may
be talk okay I've heard of that at least
which is always good and it isn't even
all the way down turtle stutters okay
turtle okay then what's triples which is
a simple line based font show them what
and do you want to list all of them or
chests no no it's just the top ones and
ones that show diversity and what we can
do and then we will have a separate page
that lists them explicitly next json-ld
then rdf/xml
you
you
yes that's it that we need to list or is
there another one that we should show
just to show the diversity what we can
do so those are the format's plus two
more that include RDF data but then we
can also import and export host portal
queries that would be called Sparkle
query or sparkle update
I thought was any good there are the
most important ones okay okay so now let
me actually do one other thing here um
let me see I want to look for everything
that has JSON in it um ah select percent
string contains Q hash comma JSON
actually I'm going to look for Sun okay
it's everything okay fine ah okay let's
just do the same thing for dollar export
formats just to check there's nothing
and almost there OOP same thing okay
good alright um okay so then we've got
these we need a page then oh we've got
another XML format down here right so do
we want to list that
XML formats are clearly on this page
here um we need to list this right as an
XML format what is what is the XML
format that you are talking about here
RDF XML which is also an RTF format for
encoding or if data
okay so that's probably yes a separate
section here are there any other xml's
let's just check here um
okay so we got those two to list on this
page right
yes basically the same notes as in the
case of chase
you
by the way to make sure that there are
seal cells between those JSON okay um
xml representation of rdf linked data
and that data type what what is the what
is the name there
hmm I don't understand look more worth
what's the file name file type Oh
RDS okay and the other one we need to
fill these in by the way over here um
what is the one for json-ld what's the
file extension or chasin LD boggle
endpoint results what's the file
extension
what is our J okay and if you can't find
it for geo JSON if somebody can find
that at ease yeah shield Jason
and these two
what do we call these
that both of these are Jason isn't that
correct
yes and what's our expression Jason
called it's also Jason okay all right
let's go back down here so what is this
one Sparkle Sparkle XML
why are we calling it that when it's
actually called srj I used for all those
font formats a camel cased version or
abbreviation whatever seems most
appropriate
but why aren't we just calling this rdf
here
mmm in a document it's called rdf/xml
and what document does standard defines
its audio
XML okay all right what do we say here
we say um it's it's equivalent for
basically the same as sparker results
Jason just take some elevation of it
um okay XML format used by Sparkle
endpoints and then what got what is it
yes our ex you know I have to say that I
don't know why we're calling it I mean a
lot of these other things like SVG we
could call it scalable vector graphics
but we're not we're calling an SVG when
people talk about this do they talk
about srj and SRX so they talk about the
longer names question yes I I haven't
seen so much conversation about them
because those formats are on the
background I guess all right well I
think you should look at that of whether
they whether they should be named you
know to go along with our other format
names you know this could be called java
view but it's not it's called jbx so you
know we generally name it by the
extension when we can when there is a
reasonable extension make sense yes so
see this called SRX srj okay why don't
you get back to me in a day
and we'll change it in these places okay
make sense follow me to change if you
make that if you believe in the change
then make the change
okay I researched okay okay so meanwhile
here you need to produce a page audio
and sparkle related formats okay um and
okay we are out of time here but
boy there's a lot of stuff here okay
okay well great
well I'm glad that um at least um ah
okay call on our live stream is saying
I've only ever seen the longer names
used okay that's useful thank you um
okay so maybe we'll leave the longer
names okay um
okay right anything else just very
quickly that we should go over here
maybe a quick look at sparkle select ref
page which has made it their most
important entry point
you
let me ask you a question our XML stuff
have you looked at it recently I mean
it's quite old well I I have used it for
instance to implement already affects it
now do you like it I was hoping that the
twist project would make certain things
simpler for instance inheritance if if
you define say the base and an xml
property then that should be inherited
to lower-level elements have you
communicated that to Jose because I
think the trees project is about to
become active again okay
okay all right Sparkle selector
is this lazy or not dosa all operators
like query our system simple query
which means
but it's applied to a graph yes or it is
fat to Sparkle execute which is on
sparkle execute is taking a particular
end point to which it is applying those
queries yes
you
hmm okay you know the fact that you
always have to define these is really
annoying yes
so I'm considering some new mechanism
something like RDF prefix data that has
some common things predefined what I'm
experimenting with it
well but the issue is there
also got this notion of external
identifier
look the main point is you don't want to
have to say I mean if you had external
identifier of schema schema.org comma
and then the name at least it saves this
ridiculous string joining business yes
so the ideas that you could say RDF
prefix data of schema comma person and
that would give you the long IRI for the
cater for the case of certain well-known
prefixes that people have to curate yeah
I understand but that's what external
identifier is supposed to support those
things as well so we need to understand
how those correspond yes um oh it's an
interesting question from the live
stream should data repository entries be
available in json-ld
so the entity stores I don't even know
what we're providing that's a really
good point actually because in the data
repository many things are pure
you know many things here are pure
so for example we probably should have a
section in here for graph databases um
but but here for example we have some
entity stores there's the question of
how can you download that entity store
what I cake is this again
you
what is that again I thought that have
been fixed well anyway this is supposed
to have some download mechanism right
but this is
and also by the way this needs to be
fixed use register entities andraia that
that's for you to communicate please
your understanding
hello
hmm I thought Draya was here did you
understand joining to repeat sorry I
said this needs two things first of all
that era needs to be reported it was
supposed to have been fixed
second this here needs to turn in to
register and entity register entity
register instead of this nonsense with
repent two entities doors and the final
point is that everything that is an
entity store here presumably should be
downloadable in something like this
json-ld format yes
so for certain basic data I have mapping
prototype and what I want to extend that
to make it possible to export and import
as much as possible data between entity
and native state and ODF no no I
understand it but I'm saying
specifically for those data repository
entries which are entity stores we
should be able to use already F for
those yes and what I mean is that this
can could be automated in certain cases
isn't it having to create okay so Karl
on livestream is saying D cat would be
the ontology to use I don't know what D
cat is
what is D cut you don't know either
I've seen it but I don't know I look at
it it seems to be this whatever
um yes yes that would be helpful to
allowing certain tensions for instance
to make our data sets discouraged or
more easily
you
it is for providing metadata of datasets
I see like Dublin core it says this
looks kind of I wonder whether anybody's
actually using it I mean the fact that
this was far down on the search thing
ah
he built it okay interesting the I wait
a minute to built this here's the
sparkle package to work with the
repository
okay
you
okay so what is this this is
so what should we be able to read this
end this is a dot TTL file should we be
able to read this just be able to say
it's important there okay let's give it
a try
maybe import comma turtle oh but alert
from the file extension so what should
we do here what can we do here well not
explore
that's still a little bit complicated
you have to write Sparkle queries to
look into it
can't what what would you expect to be
able to do in the future would you
expect to be able to get like if I
wanted a graph of relationships here
we cooked a visualization functions for
that but roughly how would I do this
first of all
spartak very d'etre treatise on
properties or the entities to get an
overview of what's in there
um
sorry say that again so one thing I
usually do is to get a list of
properties to see what's in there find
some typical entities
give me an example of a query yeah
spark a select of RDF triple off and
then three Sparkle variables sparkle
variable what variable this is not
simple in case you were wondering yes
okay now what then the string once it's
s both scream what it's exciting yes
and then another variable for predicate
an object Alko variable and then what is
prepare for predicate yes what am I
doing here I'm not typing the wrong
thing Sparkle variable of object okay
and then what and then goes to spot a
variable P what are we doing here that's
a projection because we want only the P
variable okay comma the state cost o
true the
distant radicals Oh God
yes and that's an operator that you can
apply to the data set you retrieved okay
what on earth just happened here
yes so this gives you a list of
solutions and the solution is basically
a match with a list of binding
Association of bindings so this is then
saying that those are the
those are the predicates that are in
this data set yes
so for example if I were to make but
roughly if what I wanted here was if
let's say that what I wanted was this I
want subject goes to object so if I
can't understand how to do this you
can't have an expression there the right
answer why not
what did this do something completely
wrong oh it just didn't it didn't it
didn't say what I was trying to do is
get the graph of what subjects are
related to what objects
in that ontology
now so the right hand side can only be a
list so this should probably fail better
but the right hand side should only be a
list of variables okay so then this is
like this right yes okay fine so why
does this say
okay so then IRI but while it wasn't a
list of I our eyes on right there so
there I see I see I see that okay so
there so if I say values slash out that
then those are pairs of IR eyes then I
say rule triple at that and then I say
Dada Dada graph
okay there we have it
subject/object relationship in that in
that thing yes and you've got restricted
to only
property by replacing Sparkle variable P
this an actual IRI right right this is
pretty nice I'm gonna store this just
because and we could even use why don't
we use some we can use Carl's ontology
and our examples why not if it's going
to be their stable
hard see where is this this is under
Sparkle um
okay I need to go to a different meeting
here but but um very cool um and it's
very encouraging that this just worked
here very encouraging I mean it's hardly
yeah um okay actually there's one more
comment on our on our livestream D cat
would only be useful if use microdata on
web pages how I see for SEO
okay well separate separate issues um
and
that's a trusting look at the
or could all those clusters that we can
have presumably I don't know if we have
it let's just just for the heck of it
let's just see oh never mind I was
thinking we could just do one of these
with so actual property there just to
see this and more more detail can you
figure out what a property is in this
and the sum in this thing maybe she'll
go up there's the list of properties oh
these were the list of properties here
so you can copy and paste an IRA okay
well let's say um publisher here okay so
then I go
and that's a specific IRI right yes and
you could if you like even get rid of
two right inside of the rule
well doesn't matter let's do that
what's the publishers values okay
[Music]
magnificent have we say that son 13 and
we say vertex
oh dear well that's a baguette I thought
that was gonna happen I mean that's how
that's something we should talk to the
vertex labeling the graph people about
because this is this is not there's
gonna come up whenever you do stuff like
this actually we probably want a
labeling function there to UM to pick
out just the pieces that are relevant so
if
go further you could try to retrieve the
RDF as label for each of those
identifiers and then use them for
labeling right okay anyway I gotta go
very nice talk to you talk to you soon
thank you for the comments on the live
stream very useful much appreciated
okay see you later